that's right lee for the last three
years i've studied the ancient teaching
of booty a booty
and did you get to relax over the
holidays
[Music]
holiday i'm a have a holiday i'm not
like chris tucker one film six years
[Applause]
what's it like in china with jackie chan
is it just ridiculous he's the man
jackie owned everything he's like you
like hotel
you said you like hotels say yeah it's
my hotel that's my hotel no
i got to do more movies but he really
just goes over and just like walks
around with like 15 people and then i'm
like in the back of the 15 people jackie
wait up hold up
this don't look right man we're supposed
to be together
okay chris tucker
jackie
jackie again
jack we would love to see that we'd love
to see that his name is lee god damn it
lee we would love to see that
i don't even remember the song you
should see him how do you sing michael
jackson are you going to reducing
michael jackson dangerous
god is so dangerous
[Applause]
that's an odd choice of songs of all the
michael jackson stories to go with
dangerous
you're the one that bought dangerous do
you keep in touch with michael do you
talk to him regularly i see him maybe a
blue moon because he's all over the
world sometimes we bump into each other
when we're traveling like we bumped into
last time we was in london and i knew
michael was in the hotel because
everybody was outside yelling at mike oh
my god and i was mad because my window
they was yelling in my window i said
michael's on the other side of the
gotta get some sleep i gotta interview
in the morning have you even introduced
jackie to michael yet i don't know have
michael i don't know michael wanna meet
jackie though he always hit me i'm gonna
name him he did call me
did you call me one time
i was just sleeping he called my my
second assistant to answer the phone uh
can i have a chip who's speaking this is
michael my my sister michael what
michael jackson
okay i'm sorry that it and then my hang
up the phone then afternoon and i wake
up because i'm wearing a night show and
wake up
you know big brother they call me
michael jackson no
yes michael jason what did you call me
why didn't you call me he talked so low
he probably thought he was somebody was
playing on the phone oh yeah well it
could have been that that could have
been the case speak up mike
critter beat it well and you're not my
brother i'm not your brother
all the stuff we've been through
rush hour one rush hour two
[Music]
take us back i mean i often hear you
talking about how communication
sometimes was obviously a problem
because his english is not that great my
english is not that great neither
either so it it it worked kafil kafit oh
what's his name is fish shelterfish
kaphil
gafilzo you know what this is
what is it
a filter fish it's filled the fish
wanted this uh what's the name of the
fish
fish
you know and it was that's that's how we
felt on the set we were so comfortable
around each other because jackie would
mess up i would mess up and we was like
both outsiders from hollywood you know
so we was like we would do anything you
know say anything to each other because
we was we was comfortable we knew we had
no ego with the whole thing and jackie
trusted me on a lot of stuff and that's
rare you know you always you know one
actor might have a big ego you might
that chemistry might not work
but jackie was coming from hong kong and
i'm coming from stand up so he was like
man you know we don't care let's just
make this work jackie didn't care like
yo be funny whatever help this movie
work you know so then what's the honor
in there
you believe in your father
wasting his life the head diving doctor
they must not go to bro you're right man
let's go tell her
the success of the movie was that a
surprising if you guys were just kind of
winging it like the first one well first
i was kind of scared because he never
spoke
he didn't say any he didn't say anything
in the first meeting when we met each
other what do you mean he didn't say
anything his managers we had all our
managers and well you guys remember each
other we was in a meeting and then we
was talking about the movie getting
ready to do the movie and uh jackie
didn't say nothing the whole time and he
was just like shaking his head
okay okay and i thought i pulled the
directors aside after me i said does he
speak english man we it's no way we can
do this movie if he don't speak english
man i got to have him communicating with
me he said don't worry he's just
checking you out he's checking out
that's what they do just he's chinese
he's just checking it out i said i
needed to say something or something you
know so um that was the whole thing i
came up with do you understand the words
that are coming out of my mouth because
i was like the first time i met her i
was like do you understand english
doesn't speak
as soon as she could blink this seafood
surface shift seafood service as soon as
she could blink the street fights you
are very
we tried to make russia one and sit in
the meeting room
you should keep talking are you looking
non-stop i i cannot say one word i don't
know how to answer
okay it's certainly nice meeting you
then gone
then when he come back hey jackie why
don't you talk i said i don't understand
what he's saying
hey man everybody has everybody ready
[Laughter]
see how difficult is that my english he
even cannot see three words chinese
jackie is the nicest guy in the whole
world i wanna let y'all know that's why
those movies were so good because jackie
was so nice and i was so comfortable but
jackie would give me a gift every day
first rush hour jackie chan would give
me a gift every day i finished my
trailer yeah i'm like what is going on
he's so nice and i had to buy him
something after a while i gotta get him
some but then i realized he's from china
they make everything over there he was
getting it for free
well i almost went broke trying to keep
up with him say hello to your dad
hello yeah
i'm filming man no you can't speak to
jackie chan
no
they want to speak to you jack hello i'm
sorry about this we we are filming right
now
are you sorry you waste our film
cause when the dark gets colder i'll
call you over you know i
[Music]
jackie used to make me look bad he used
to show up to work on time all the time
i said jackie you're the star man take
it easy trailer you're making me look
bad man he said chris you're messing
you're wasting money you don't set on
time yourself
you said it ain't your money jackie
no seriously wanna brother he is like
that he oh yeah he's prom man he's a
great dude dude man love him man and
when you work with him he his english
isn't great so you have to hang
jackets on every word right jackie i'll
be having jackie words all on me on on
paper what you call it like a cardboard
to be taped on me behind the camera like
that don't move don't move oh man i
can't do that he said you're standing
there we did spy next door and it was he
said it's gonna be hard to get that kid
and jackie said we have to get that kid
hard
[Applause]
that's what made the movies great at the
end oh yeah and then it's contagious
yeah yeah and i messed up one time he
just acted a fool see you messed up you
messed up look at you you can't even
read chris you crazy
i put on um luther vandross and uh teddy
pendergrass
you got you got you got what i need
y'all don't know about that
me i like
country song
yes because when i
learning country song i can speak
english like wise men say like you are
always on my mind then i really can use
it in my real life you are always on my
mind you know
but some wrong
too quick i cannot hear
you anything goes wrong you busting the
act like you had lap
there cannot speak english
damn
he ain't gonna be in rush hour three